crash away to find out if Apple's new
car crash detection really works
[Music]
you just have to crash some cars
Michael anything yes a few weeks ago
Apple introduced the new iPhone 14
models and apple watches with
crash detection
Apple Watch series 8 can detect if you
were in a severe car crash when a crash
is detected it will automatically
connect you with Emergency Services
Apple's feature comes three years after
Google added it to its pixel phones now
the hope is that none of us ever have to
rely on this Tech to save our lives but
that's all the more reason we want to
know does it actually work and what sort
of crashes does it work in
thank you
and that's why we came out here to the
fields and junkyards of Monroe Michigan
which also happens to be home to some
world-class Derby drivers
and the hometown of my producer Kenny
it's not Monroe oh say it again Monroe
after I failed to trigger the crash
detection Alert in bumper cars
nothing detected we decided to find
someone who bumps real cars I'm Michael
Berry and I'm a three-time figure eight
Derby champ yep Michael competes called
Figure Eight derbies
[Applause]
his car consisting of a sturdy steel
frame and not much else is designed to
withstand tough crashes so we offered to
do a series of crashes for us with
phones and watches on board how does
that feel good an RS recycling offered
up two soon-to-be shredded cars to crash
into
please do not do this at home we took a
lot of precautions to make sure this was
done safely Michael is wearing a
four-point harness and a helmet
we also had Nicole Branham a certified
EMT standing by in case anything were to
happen and of course during all crashes
everyone but the driver stood at a safe
distance I'm hiding from the crash tell
me when it happens okay let's see if
this works here's how I set up this not
exactly scientific test
Michael is driving his derby car with an
Apple Watch Ultra on his wrist and an
iPhone 14 and a Google pixel strapped in
next to him
the Ford Taurus has an iPhone 14 pro Max
and a pixel 6 mounted to its dashboard
vents
on the new iPhones and apple watches
crash detection is enabled out of the
box on Google's pixel phones however you
have to turn it on in the personal
safety app
okay here we go
[Music]
so tell us what happens we first thing
looked at the watch nothing nothing and
it probably was like a five to ten
second delay it then popped up would you
like to contact contact emergency
services Michael tapped the cancel
button here but had he not the watch
would have initiated a 10 second
countdown before calling emergency
services
Apple designed the feature so if you're
wearing the watch paired to an iPhone
the watch will display the alert as it
will likely remain on a person when a
crash occurs
the pixel and Michael's car didn't
trigger and the phones in the Taurus
didn't either
so how does this technology work
the new iPhone models along with the
Watch series 8 and Ultra have a three
access gyroscope and a high GeForce
accelerometer which samples motion at
over 3000 times a second
it means that when a car is going really
fast and then abruptly stops or slows
down it's able to sense the precise
moment of impact or the change in that
motion the sensors and algorithms look
for other things too including a change
in pressure when airbags deploy when
windows are closed and the microphones
can measure sound levels so it makes
sense that Michael's car which was
moving at approximately 25 miles per
hour triggered the alert
but what about the phones in the Taurus
so we tried again
and again
on the second crash the pixel and
Michael's car triggered an alert it says
I'm okay
but the pixel and the iPhone in the
Taurus never went off it's a bummer
especially if someone was actually in
this car
which brings us to car number two
so this is gonna do it the windows go up
and it will drive see I figured that
there were a few things off with the
Taurus notably that it wasn't being
driven so the phones didn't think they
were in a car
plus the windows were open when the
airbags deployed this time before the
crash to help the phones recognize they
were in a moving vehicle we drove the
van around first
[Music]
car stopped at a stop sign two phones
are in
there we go
Michael's watch detected the crash so
did mine as I had put my iPhone in
Michael's car and was in close enough
proximity for it to alert me
cancel
but despite the airbags deploying in the
Dodge nothing went off that's insane
when I contacted apple with the results
a company spokesman said that the
testing conditions in the junkyard
didn't provide enough signals to the
iPhone to trigger the feature in the
stopped cars it wasn't connected to
Bluetooth or carplay which would have
indicated that the car was in use and
the vehicles might not have traveled
enough distance prior to the crash to
indicate driving a Google spokesman said
that the algorithm first needs to detect
that you're driving then the feature can
detect crashes even if the vehicle is
stationary so what did we learn here
today when it works this technology
could really be life-saving three times
today we could have had calls into
emergency services within 30 seconds
without anyone lifting a finger but from
all our testing it's clear that there's
a gray area both about what the system
considers to be a severe enough crash
and even how the system establishes that
it's in a car in the first place
to be fair Apple says this right in the
fine print on every iPhone though it
doesn't provide any specifics
still you may feel better knowing that
your phone or watch can do this
oh and stay away from Derby cars
you drive like your grandma
[Laughter]